i'm going to give you a little tour of
the set
as we know about bridgeton it's saucy
i've never understood why it's steamy
and everything else that you need to see
happens upstairs
it doesn't get more dramatic or dishier
it's very
all of those things that you would
imagine
we've had an intimacy coach which i've
never had before in a job
daphne will not merely be in society she
will be leading it you keep them
watching by having a balance between the
and the it's about love it's about
jealousy it's about
relationships and it's quite nice to
just
be human about it really it's not your
granny's period drama
let it be known if there's a scandal
i shall uncover it lady whistle down
certainly stirs
can't say that word but stuff up
massively
the please after you
[Music]
hello my name is jonathan bailey i play
anthony bridgeton on the new
netflix show ridgeton and i'm going to
give you a little tour of the set
come with me come this way
[Music]
and just another day in the british
tournament there's always about
two units going at any point there's
skip
who's the best of the business over
there
it keeps everything in focus focus is
important in set bridges
everyone's lining up here as you can see
and what what's amazing is we have like
hundreds of hundreds of brilliant people
who come forward and they create the
whole world and they're all the
supporting artists
and with the design of ellen the costume
is just insane and all that happens
so it's everywhere you look the design
is just like completely on point so
we're completely spoiled every single
day
the duke of hastings now known forever
more i'm playing simon bassett
um in bridgeton and he is a dark
shadowy broken mysterious generous
intelligent
loving young man who has absolutely no
idea how to bring those things together
into any kind of workable cocktail
um and instead is very much playing ring
of fire with all of those liquors and
it's not a good place to be though
eloise i do believe you will know what
love feels like soon enough next season
you think i have to follow in your
footsteps sister
there'd be a more dreadful fate we play
two of the bridgeton siblings i play
anthony who's the firstborn
and i play eloise number five
and um eloise is
sort of the lovable rogue i guess of the
family quite brazen
um and sort of i think because of her
place in the family
she will be the next daughter on the
marriage market but she's sort of
far enough in that she can she's got
room to find out what she wants
do you know what is an accomplishment
attending university
and i don't think it's anything that
daphne's sort of going through
we're scribbling in that diary of yours
and
she's she writes and she smokes in the
garden
she's a bit of a she's a rogue 1813
rebel
yeah dead fun you have no idea what it
is to be a woman
daphne you're a bridgette would be
easier if i or not
up north is anthony he's
yeah the firstborn so he's bearing the
weight of um of
uh heritage and and the whole he has the
responsibility of making sure that his
sisters and brothers get married off um
to secure their future
i had to find your husband's sister now
be grateful it is done
and works with his mum in a quiet they
have quite a tempestuous relationship
but he um yeah like eloise is
questioning very different things what
it is to be
a man and what it is to be able to be
there for other people and to make sure
that you look after yourself at the same
time
which i think is a very modern very very
modern thing
do you think this is wise whatever do
you mean colin is young
he is from seriously thinking about
marriage and i would hate to think
marina is simply wasting her time time
she simply does not have of course
that is all penelope is a very
interesting character she's a really
she's really beloved by the fans of the
books so i felt a certain way of
pressure
no i guess knowing i was going to play
her i would never bring scandal on you
or our family
if that is what you ask but i could not
condone your actions
and i was sort of terrified and i knew
the day the announcement was coming out
and i was like what if they hate me and
they're like
she's totally wrong but they couldn't
have been sweeter and yeah i'm really
determined to do her justice she's a
very clever girl
she's really ahead of her time and i
think you see lots of different sides of
her because with her family she's very
shy and
held back she's not really able to
express herself and then when she's with
eloise she totally gets to chill out and
there
yeah two girls again both of them very
ahead of their time and then she's madly
in love with colin
so that's a big thing too full of you at
one table
what are the children i realize it may
be unfashionable but
we like each other most of the time
violet the matriarch
she's she's a very warm character she's
uh
she adores her children she uh would
defend them to the hilt
when we meet her she is adamant about
getting her children married off
for love to an equal um
she wants what she had in her marriage
for her children
would it pain you to wear some color
your grace
london season is already terribly
monotonous as it is
must your wardrobe do the same i'm
playing lady dandry
she's a darija duchess um she has lots
of money
she's a widow she has no children
so in this society she's about as free
as a woman can get
but she's got the status she's got the
money she's got
um that place in society where she's a
game player in town
so if lady danbury is out in public lady
danbury is
on uh so yeah so she's
on uh so the costumes have to be on
as well um and we've just got the most
amazing
design team for hair and makeup and
and costumes and everything and and and
beautiful makers as well
so we just gone for fabulous fabrics
and we decided what sort of design shape
we wanted obviously it's got to be
in the period but then all of this show
is in the period but with schwang
and that goes for everything from
costume to casting to
sets to whatever come on might you spare
me a moment
i must have crested his opinion on some
fabric her taste is
impeccable when i got the job i kind of
before we started filming there was like
a form
four week period of fittings and wig
fittings i think i had like
five different wigs before we found the
right one just getting the right color
and the right look
um but ugh i mean it does have the job
for you
the beautiful costumes and the beautiful
hair and makeup
so yeah it's been amazing it's like
you did you you discover your character
as you're getting dressed and as
claire puts up my hair or does the
makeup then you sort of
it slots into place and it's nice it's a
nice help
[Music]
today you're here with me in the british
and wardrobe truck full of these amazing
amazing costumes
so i am part of the featherington family
and i will tell you if you walked into a
ballroom in 1813 london
you are going to notice these girls
because we have a serious color palette
there is lots of citrus colors so you've
got your yellows your greens this is my
sister prudence's dress
like incredibly embellished all
hand-stitched flowers
this is another one of prudences we do
have a lot of pinks too a lot of florals
but you know a rule with a featherington
dress is if you think you've done too
much
add a little bit more you want to get
some bling you know we've got
little dimantes here and this dress 3d
flowers
silk ribbons and then you can move over
to the bridgetons who have
a much softer more romantic look so
these are some of violet's dresses
and they're really dreamy and beautiful
they've made 4 000 individual costumes
for this show
including every supporting artist has a
bespoke
handmade piece and that's what makes the
look of it so so spectacular
this is one of my favorite dresses on
the production this is one of my sister
philippa's dresses
and this was for our we went for a
garden party
and this it has loads of flowers in the
bottom but they actually move around
they're loose and this is another one
this is when we were at
the ball where we're crested of faints
faints for the prince
so again lots of florals and phillips
colors there's a lot of green
for her palette so the three sisters are
kind of green
orange and i'm yellow i'm a definite
yellow
fans of julia quinn's books will know
that poor penelope is described as
looking like an overripe citrus fruit by
lady whistle down
not very nice so she wears a lot of
bright yellow but you'll see
what they have done with yellow dresses
in the show is incredible what i'm
wearing today each of the flowers are
hand stitched
there's an embellishment room in the
costume area
so everything is completely decorated
all the jewelry is made on this show
every single costume you see has been
handmade nothing is rented which is so
unusual but it makes
the look of the show so spectacular and
so so different it's like kind of a punk
take on regency
so another amazing thing about the
costumes on this job is
something that you actually can't see on
camera so
all of our corsets on this job were
bespoke by mr pearl
you might not know who that is but you
may have seen kim kardashian's look at
the met gala where she had that teeny
teeny tiny waist
or indeed the vantes you know the famous
burlesque artist
their courses were also made by mr pearl
so it's like wearing
art every single day and it makes you
stand completely differently and it
makes you really feel like you're in
that era
the way you stand up i will tell you
after 14 hours in one
you are quite happy to take it off but
during the day
it adds so much to it and you know
there's a lot there's a lot going on
under here
a lot going on ellen mirage nick and
john glaser did such an amazing
job with the costumes we really knew
that costumes were going to be important
to the show like they are in every
period piece
but with our show we really wanted to
elevate the costumes and bring in
this kind of fresh modern edge to
everything
that we do it will be the grandest
wedding of the year tulips enough to
fill the great room and the finest silks
only the best this is one of the
favorites i have to admit
um and yeah we're having loads and loads
of fun
kind of creating these looks um
that hopefully will be iconic you know
what we're doing on this show is kind of
judging it up a little bit you know
these the wig that i'm wearing at the
moment is
one of many queen charlotte doesn't have
any kind of
um what's the word continuity so
you'll see her in lots of different
outfits lots of different wigs
and it kind of adds to the creativity of
her character
um she's quite feisty
she's uh loves a gossip
that one is a terrible gossip if we were
to speak freely in his presence before
long the whole of england would know our
business
i kind of describe it as kind of gossip
girl meets eric
marie antoinette that kind of vibe
um so it's really really exciting to be
yeah donning such things
[Music]
chris van diesen is the creator he said
this is not like this is not your
granny's period drama
this is sexy exciting it's fun it's like
it's definitely regency but with like a
level of punk
but yeah lady whistle down stirs i can't
say that word but stuff
up massively i think
um yes you could say gossip girl meets
downton abbey in that
downton abbey is a period thing and
we've got this this mystery
character who's sort of this omniscient
narrator who's sort of talking about
that sort of kind of gossip girl land
but i would say that uh we're we're
we're further out there than that
and that's what's really exciting it's
like yeah we're in period
and the settings our regency and we and
we are
seeing some of the most fabulous
architecture and grounds and all of that
that's absolutely in period but then
there's this extra swing to it that sort
of heightens it above the period we do
have a character
lady whistle down who is this this
gossip writer of
19th century regency london and she just
writes the most scathing things but
she says it with such a beautiful
beautiful loving tone and smile and
that's actually going to be narrated by
julie andrews my name
is lady whistle down
you do not know me and never shall she
is incredible i mean it's julie andrews
what what is there to really say about
julie andrew she's a legend and it's
it's been amazing working with her i
certainly know
you when i found out julie andrews was
going to be in the show i cried
i was standing in a kitchen with my mom
and i was scrolling through instagram
and i saw her picture
and then just read lady whistle down and
i just started completely bawling and
it's amazing they literally could not
have found a better person it was
quite a pinch me moment when for the
first time
i saw up on the board my picture was not
very far away from julie andrews that
was really quite exciting
the social season is upon us
we shall discover which young ladies
might succeed at securing a match
we go through here i've actually the
thing about bridgestone is there's loads
of balls of loads of regency balls we
have these incredible locations
and old uh historic houses um and this
one as you can tell
peacock is a bird themed ball it's the
prince's ball
in episode three i think of which my
character doesn't go
so that's how i could sort of chill out
and show you behind the scenes
so with my my favorite places on set are
the the areas just off the main action
because
it's usually where you can get away with
doing all sorts of new things and
and we as a company as a cast really
really get on so you will always find a
sibling it's just offset like
being naughty and giggling and having a
wild time
but there's always this is so this is
another section and this is
clearly they're dressing this to look
like some sort of
i don't know gorgeous crystal
uh renaissance bejazzle bejeweled
haven and of course this is really
similar to
my house at home as all brits do live in
these
sweeping staircase halls if this was mtv
cribs
i'd welcome you to my gcse art
my year 11 artwork there
we've got all the monitors here they're
all already looking through in different
different balls that's happening next
door but i'm going to send you up
the staircase you can go and check out
my boudoir
as we know about bridgeton it's saucy
and steamy
and everything else you need to see
happens upstairs
so please after you
if you would have only looked at me this
week
for longer than two seconds you would
have seen
it is you i cannot sacrifice
i burn for you
it doesn't get more dramatic or dishier
it's a full-on
dinner plate lunch plate and breakfast a
dish nothing but dish
it's very steamy and it's very all of
those things that you would imagine
and but it's also regency england so
it's kind of a new
take on that and i think it's quite
exciting to see that world and yet to
see
kind of more behind the scenes and more
yeah
more fiery we've had an intimacy coach
um which i've never had before in a job
which is amazing to work with so she's
great
um we rehearse everything almost like a
stunt
um but yeah it's lucky to have someone
like reggae that i work with who we get
on really well with and
we get on really well and um yeah we
just make it fun
and easy so it's great this is a very
steamy program i know i'm gonna have to
warn my mom we'll just get you the
censored version
there's definitely a lot but it's you
know what it's really fun it's like
pure beautiful escapism and penelope 2
is a character that's a true romantic
and i don't think you see that very much
these are characters who are
confined in a really strict and
oppressive society an area of society
which means that their questioning is
extreme for them to
sort of deviate from what's expected of
them is a huge thing and the
implications are massive so
the tensions and the stakes are high all
the way through and
you know of course you know the first
orgasm wasn't in
hbo dramas so you know they are also
finding themselves in their identity and
of course through that is their
sexuality and what that means and
what the parameters are
daphne and simon have this like really
intense
will they won't they thing which i think
we can all relate to
um and that's so powerful
to watch and then these sideline stories
of it's head
versus heart yeah which is that old
romantic notion and julia quinn i think
in the books has written something that
everyone can really like
enjoy and celebrate the idea of young
love and what that is and finding that
person
i'm not involved in any of the steamy
bits
i have to have words about that later on
my character isn't in the books
so that's very exciting so
it kind of gives me a little bit of
license to play around
um with queen charlotte and the kind of
period
and what she's about it is not the
archbishop
it is the queen perhaps she has taken
your rejection of her nephew to heart
or perhaps she is simply bored either
way it does not bode well for your
daughter's social future
nor any of the bridgetons for that
matter how do you keep people watching
you keep them watching by having a
balance between the
and so there's a lot of that going on in
this show there's lots of will they
won't lay there's lots of side
stories there's drama in the settings
you know
there's drama in the look of these
spectacular balls
you know and then you get these really
quiet intimate moments and they have
their own quiet drama too
so yeah there's a lot going on obviously
i'm not in costume yet so i probably
should go and do that but
before i do that i'm going to show you
this is another one of the most
incredible sets
and as you can see these are all flowers
that have been hand linked
together it's just all the attention to
detail and bridges and sets just
completely
wild and it's we're completely spoiled i
don't think it's ever going to be like
this again
there's always so many different balls
and so many different locations that
actually i feel like some sort of
renaissance time traveler like sort of
doctor who we just turn up every day and
just
get mind blown but look at the amazing
ceilings and the intricate
intricacies we um if we like really into
history we turn up and
there's always people on set unlike the
locations who give you like a full
backdrop of all the
historic uh context for the properties
that we're in we've been in the place
where
um jane seymour had her child we were
filming there
in that very room in fact that was our
green room which seemed a bit
sacrilegious but
you know life moves on everything
evolves and now we're here on the set of
bridges
with all historical um period dramas you
always do a lot
of research you do research constantly
all the way through the job
something comes into a script that you
have to look into
but on top of that because this is a
sort of heightened world
you know me and my team have been
looking at other references like dior
cecil beaton even and the old 1940s
period shows period films because the
look of those
is very much in the keeping of where we
want to be there's so many like i said
there's so many intricate rules
and social structures of the time that
it was important to me
and to the producers to really have an
etiquette person there on set
advising us you know there was a
historian who read every script
and there's an etiquette advisor on set
every day to really
you know talk about you know how to sit
at a dinner table how to
eat you know the the rules of courtship
you know the
curtsies and the nods and the greetings
all of all of those things are really
important to capture
and stay true to the time period
etiquette training we learned how to bow
to the queen
we're learning about you know dinner and
correction like you know you have to
always
i had a scene with with nick newton who
plays colin where he came over and we
just sort of started talking and they
went
no no no it doesn't matter that you've
known each other since you were kids
you know now you're both you know you're
both out in society so the dynamic
changes
but learning about all of them we have
an amazing historical supervisor called
hannah and she
she helps us out and but just the cool
things like little dance cards and stuff
and
i think because the production design is
so incredible it helps immerse you in
that world very very quickly
you feel like you're in it i always
think the thing to hold on to is
people are always the same it doesn't
matter what period you put them in
i don't think there's anything different
that's ever been people are always the
same with the same
they just sort of socially interact in
slightly different ways but the
motivations are still the same
so you may be doing you know that but
really what you might be saying is
drop dead you know you mean it's so it's
those
you know it's it's the nuances of how
you use the physicality of the period or
whatever
the niceties is the period but you're
still kind of saying the same stuff
so julia quinn wrote these lovely
delightful
books called the bridgeton series shonda
said she had these books and i read
these books and i was
immediately hooked as a woman of color
how could i not be thrilled to be
working for shonda rhines and i'm also
thrilled to
say yeah do you know what people of
color
existed in this country right back to
roman times
and you know regency london had 20 000
black people
20 000 that's not a small
number so it's really it's really great
to be able to be
in a period drama because we were in the
period we just weren't in the drama
it's one of those dream come true
moments uh
you know as a dropping actor you kind of
dream of these moments that
uh that will change your life and for me
i
feel very very blessed and very honoured
to be
i think she really draws people in and
draws the audiences in
and there's something for everybody you
know the
um the kind of content and form and
everything i think
really reaches out to a worldwide
audience
from loving their tv shows you would
they always
seem to write really immediate vital
storylines
which are really accessible and they
represent people that are watching the
show
i feel like this just so happens to be a
period drama
do you know what you mean like it just
so happens to look like dead lovely
and have this really like fancy backdrop
but with this as like a shared humanity
that i think the audience will find with
everyone
[Music]